albert was already a legend during his lifetime as a
successful writer as a
philosopher on
womanizer his philosophical discovery is
still provocative today because like all great
philosophers he naturally
asked the question about the meaning of life
but his answer is completely
out of the
ordinary of course the question of meaning is  you her
answered differently just with
plato the good thing is that the world holds
together at its core with edel the
world spirit with marx the work with
nietzsche the will to power
habermas the development of language
basically every philosopher gives an answer
to the question of meaning not the way he came up with it
no
worse still results in an answer but
this answer is extremely sobering
to the question what is the meaning of
life, camille replies simply there
is none life is absurd we
always plan ahead but in
the end life only depends on a whole
series of coincidences that  we can not
influence
also there e  s no real goal our
task so kamil is nevertheless
to go on living so he compares
the life of man with the myth
of sisyphus this this legend
this foot tirelessly rolls a ball
up the mountain and this ball
then rolls down again but  precisely in
this apparently pointless act there
is a chance of a fulfilling life
we have to deal aggressively with the absurdity and i
the end we said we have
o imagine sisyphus as a happy
person the b
ok never came in 60 minutes explained at hi
best based on his best
quotes the absurd the idea of the absurd and i
the chapter what use is vegetable disco
ery today, the absur
lifestyle he recommends is descr
bed by khami
s dazzling example of absurd life
lans and his suggestions on how m
dern people can best
eal with the absurd and w
thout god without ideology  being able to
live without religion is very modern and
straightforward  e today of powerful topicality